tear up any fanfiction you've written
about Mario because it's all wrong all
of it
admit it you thought these games took
place in some alternate universe right
well it turns out the Luigi Diddy
Bowser jr. Peck the entire Mushroom
Kingdom they all exist on earth I hope
that your mind is it's blown as mine was
and I'll take a deep breath forget about
all the poor koopa troopas you've jumped
on and enjoy a fine rendition of the
world's oldest sport if you've played
any of Mario's previous golfing outings
you know that they nailed the feel of
striking a ball a long time ago tap the
power tap again for accuracy and hope
your aim is true teeing off and World
Tour immediately whisked me away to
those long hours I spent in toadstool
tour perfecting my short game the duty
of the deceptively simple action comes
in figuring out how to master the
imaginative courses there's a wind to
withstand slopes to navigate and
dastardly putting greens to curse oh and
don't go nuts at the backspin just
because it's easy perform doesn't mean
you should spin the ball in every
approach World Tour is a great fit for
the 3ds
it's pick-up-and-play mentality should
make it the panacea for any dose of
boredom sadly we'll have to wait until
May before we can see how well monkeys
can golf and in the meantime we're left
to ponder what boo did while he was
living to be stuck on earth for all
eternity